oh she's not in it anymore she left the
what snapchat hi I'm Jade I'm Perry PI
I'm Jesse
I'm the I'm from LA mix and this is
first and last for Tyler it's the first
gift I bought myself I remember when we
won the X Factor and got some money and
we all treated ourselves to UM MacBooks
when I got me first sort of peer job
singing in a restaurant I think I got 60
quid for the knife and I went straight
at Kirk I again got myself a pair of
shoes from what I can remember I think
it was an S Club 7 CD from Woolworths I
could remember getting my first a lot of
Wonga
and I bought some Missy Elliott adidas
boots and I think they're still pretty
trendy to this stray the last gift I
bought myself was um I just bought a
little Chloe cardigan I went in self
just yesterday and I got some more prada
trainers a Christian Dior Berg a nice
pashwan a court designer one I thought
I'd treat myself after the tour the
first famous person who I added into my
phone contacts but if Bentley's Oh
ELISA ELISA would be too Lisa I think
she was the first famous person I've
ever met in life and the last famous
person who I added into my phone
contacts
they have a lot of famous friends can't
lie I've got Arianna just pretty cool
we're really crap at mingling and making
friends we just all stick together when
we go to a lot of war things when we're
supposed to be mingling we don't we just
stay together like for charlotte with
school kids was probably ray because
we've seen her at the British Fashion
Awards I cannot remember the last famous
person who had the first memorable piece
of advice I received believe in myself I
think that's just the main thing really
it's probably a work hard for what you
want in life don't expect it on a please
always be yourself you can't go wrong
trying to be someone that you're not
we'll just never work and I forgot
people to always see through that
probably to just be yourself I guess
yeah I'm getting a nod of approval from
Leanne behind the camera she liked that
one so I go with that just be yourself
the last member would piece of advice I
received live every day like it's your
last because life's too short would be
to just enjoy life for what it is no
pain stressing is the never regret
anything that made you smile I just sat
down with my legs open assuming that it
would be appropriate I had tights on it
wasn't so the advice was don't sit like
that a very celebrity crush that I had
probably M Nick Carter from the
Backstreet Boys there was many a poster
him in my bedroom Lil Romeo and I
remember him the Romeo Justin Timberlake
jay-z for out there
it was either between Johnny Depp and
Jesse McCartney before I had them to all
over my walls and the last celebrity
crush that I had would probably be Lenny
Kravitz would have to be my lovely
mandem Andre my boyfriend he's a
beautiful specimen close my boyfriend
sex on lakes that one the first person I
was inspired by Missy Elliott but she's
the person who actually made me want to
be a performer probably my sister Sarah
so I really look up to her I think I
just wanted to be her when I was younger
probably my mom she's very independent
she's very strong she's very I don't
need a man does everything for herself
and she's just beautiful and just
obsessed with Diana Ross I went to see
her when I was 10 and I just thought
that's what I wanted to do when I were
the last person people should I say that
inspired me was my beautiful best mates
in the Band Perry Jaden LeAnn is just
Rihanna I would like to be like her when
I grow up even though she was cackling
in the background will probably be my
dear friend LeAnn you gonna feel guilty
now would probably be dying are us again
because she's still got it
I'm Lee Anne I'm dead I'm Jesse my
impera from Little Mix and that was
first and last for Tyler
[Music]